citizens of the reject Nation Greg here today
I am going to do a movie reaction because
this reject is missing one movie in a franchise
a franchise where I've seen all of them but
one that is the drifting of Tokyo Fast and
Furious Tokyo Drift first time watching today
but is the only one out of the Fast and Furious
films I have not seen of excluding the one
that's coming out in a few months I was like
it's about time I give this a shot I don't
know why I avoided it well I think it's because
it kind of got like a bad rep when it first
came out and whatever I'll skip it and then
uh as time's gone on people it's gotten uh
more of a what's kind of more love I think
over I really don't know what the conversation
is surrounding it all I know is I haven't
seen this movie and I was like I should just
watch it I'm gonna share my reaction with
the reject Nation so thank you all for being
here so drift on over to that like button
if you can I know you're capable of doing
it so please go ahead and do that subscribe
click the notification Bell we got more videos
coming up you know how we do here at the reject
patient is the most I've said reject nation
and intro before also full-length retro watch
along where you sync up with your own copy
of Tokyo Drift available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page so we call our
patrons makes them feel more exclusive I think
it works yeah we cover several things over
there exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included I'm watching this
off hobo Max right now alrighty guys let's
see what this is all about
I gotta put myself in a mindset before they
were superheroes foreign
because I saw him in the seventh movies or
seventh or sixth movie and I I feel like I'm
watching Like An Origin story now
and it's Han's introduction
yo it's that guy from Home Improvement nice
ride does the job delivering pizzas it's not
the ride is the rider nice hey you talking
to my girl it's a friendly conversation man
she was just a mind my ride my rod stands
for trailer trash what about your daddy's
Viper oh he's got 500 horsepower and a borley
exhaust system it does 0-60 in like 4.3 seconds
you can read the brochure [Laughter] [Music]
got it
[Music] oh hell no
why don't you nice boys let your car see the
talking I like yoga lady this car goes for
80 grand what I do with a broken ass piece
of [__] like that well if you're so confident
how about me winner gets me oh my God this
movie's so Progressive I would hate having
a girlfriend like that though goddamn now
that sucks on instability of having a relationship
where she would just prostitute herself
uh with the bottom to back into baby 2006
baby [Applause] oh damn [Applause] dude you're
not gonna win his girlfriend
is he allowed to do that
please keep your eyes forward I want you to
win I thought you loved me [Laughter] what
is this [__] seriously toxic relationship
oh dude
I guess I got a new date for prom oh my God
dude
oh my God lay off the steroids man [Music]
[Applause]
oh [__] I look painful [Applause]
oh my God
for what the Fast and Furious franchise has
become this feels more grounded you could
actually feel the pain on this [__] damn
laughs
can I get a copy of that you're going to Tokyo
son why does he go to Tokyo 100 guaranteed
conviction where's my car I crushed it you
did what sit down you understand you're done
you know before your 18th birthday now sit
down this guy's not 18. officer is it um illegal
to smoke in here says no smoking right back
there the one sign in the whole interrogation
room your son's got two priors for reckless
driving willful destruction of property they're
definitely going to get them off the streets
well there's just Tokyo so where are we moving
this time we are not moving any [Music]
that was a good transition although for a
moment I did think he was in a hospital I
guess he's going to Tokyo whatever gets us
there
'd be great to visit here look how beautiful
it is sure I thought you're going to be here
on the seventh ah okay this makes more sense
oh what is he doing at the like an American
Psycho situation you know she had no other
choice I mean it was either this or juvie
hall I mean you just can't keep moving away
every time you get into trouble theme you
go to school you come back here right after
and I don't want to see or hear about you
anywhere near a car especially no drifting
God this looks like every room John has ever
occupied or taken over
[Music]
be careful Sean you're gonna have to be racing
her on the streets later
you'll fit her right in
only the non-asian girl is checking you out
man foreign
[Music] Japanese food is like um don't ask
don't tell
names
you ain't have a laptop I'll hook you up half
price I ain't got no cash man well what about
a cell phone I'm probably not going to be
here long enough to remember your name ain't
gonna need some new shoes to book town with
me [Laughter] you selling Sparkle stand well
that's mine right there when I even pay retail
for it you paid retail my ride's One of a
Kind Show me
holy [__] is that how it works in Japan
[Music] [Laughter] [Music] foreign
oh my God I love this it's just a like a pure
Asian Fast and Furious movie where you follow
characters who are not Asians
[Music] there's one thing consistent in all
these movies it's the world of illegal street
racing and the kind of supermodels that occupy
it oh [__] how did I fail to predict that
she herself was into all this so where are
you from anyway here where'd you come from
does it really matter where I'm from
oh that's a villain look right there who's
a tourist on gaiji we were just talking that
word you call me Gaijin or something what
does that mean exactly something complimentary
I see Yakuza you know who I am boy
you like the Justin Timberlake of Japan
good luck Timber Lake [Music] whoa you're
the one that's lucky is that what it is and
let's race oh my God Sean's gonna destroy
Japan easy to sound cocky when you got no
ride take mine what the hell can he drive
can he drive you know what DK stands for Donkey
Kong drift King drift King what do you mean
drill
oh this is fun
it's fun learning all these things about Han
when I'm aware of the crazy Adventures he's
been on prior to this movie story and how
none of that was canon in the writer's praise
go let's see what's going on
yikes [Music] [Applause]
oh DK [Applause] [Laughter]
oh my God this is so embarrassing oh my God
this is so embarrassing
[Laughter] [Applause]
how is he not fat [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Laughter] God damn this is so bad
[Applause] holy [__] no way what do people
do this [Applause]
Sean give up [Applause]
I could be with a hot girl
oh he's got like five bottles there if you're
gonna live under my roof you're gonna go buy
my rules or get out understand
understand just say yeah and do what you got
to do man I'll get you your money why are
you talking like you have a choice there's
a guy in there with a paw that owes me some
money what's up Paul like a dog a bear a monkey
why we need a job hold on
[Music] so he just has to make a guess as
to who it is
that would be it on said oh Kenny
oh we just gotta put his clothes back on
[Music] let's go he is cool man I'm already
like I get why you brought this guy back might
call you once a week or once an hour I call
you show only if you teach me how to drift
stay in a negotiation I wasn't negotiator
he learned how to drift from Han not Twinkie
I thought I'd stop by and ask your boyfriend
for some drifting lessons trust me you don't
want to be a part of this world that's good
enough for you you don't know anything about
me I know you're very attractive you're an
army Brad he moved around a lot Mom and Daddy
was never home so you walked around pissed
off all the time now you found your family
with these drift nuts drift nuts zero for
one cowboy can't you go find a nice Japanese
girl like the rest of the white guys around
here
Fair Point well I need them keeps Uncle kamada
from poking around too much what do you mean
well his uncle gets a piece of the action
from everyone on this turf run this Turf 50
of something is better than 100 of nothing
that's not true it's like YouTube monetization
It's the point of a race see if I'm better
than other guys just proves you're faster
that's all that would erase it would have
to be for some important something important
[Music] show them what you got NOS
sure we might as well race why not [Music]
what the police cars the only Factory tune
you can do better than 180k they can't catch
you so they don't even try holy [__] that
can't be true I know there are countries without
speed limits let's go [Music] foreign [Music]
this movie I really wish the Fast and Furious
movie stayed in this world more
[Music] it's like he got over Giselle fast
oh my God this is heaven the red Evo's yours
what do you mean well yeah what what you think
I'm gonna let you roll in a Hyundai thank
you oh holy [__] holy [__]
[Applause]
that does look really really hard where did
you find this guy
[Applause] I really do like how this is a
genuine obstacle for him it's got potential
foreign Maybe we'll see are we talking about
the car are we talking about you Sean you're
showing the Japanese have a saying
the nail that sticks out gets hammered I don't
know when to apply that you're gonna be late
and these high school kids get real taken
advantage of thank you hey look man I don't
do refunds all right try not to break this
how iPods that it's an iPad I forgot about
iPods the hell is wrong with you huh not everybody's
going exchanges around here
we went to you Sean because we thought you
would know how to handle the situation better
than anyone else not easy saving the day is
it I mean you can give me some pointers sometime
you're doing all right thanks I love their
scenes they're always the same tone so how'd
you end up over here anyway well you know
those old westerns the Cowboys make a run
for the Border is my Mexico
I gotta go back and watch fast six now 36.
it's a trust and character I need around me
who you choose to be around you that you know
who you are that is true one car in exchange
for knowing what a man's made of that's a
price I can live with
you're an all right guy hon so if you don't
drift to win what do you drill for [Music]
the latest [Music]
foreign [Applause]
[Music]
there's a whole history to the drifting huh
watch it not too early now [Applause]
damn he's getting it of course he's gonna
get it but damn it's cool he's getting it
[Music] [Applause] [Music] damn oh my God
[Music] [Applause] I do love the a practical
stunt driving that this movie will show me
obviously some stuff will CGI but like [__]
like this man it's awesome [Applause]
hello
oh no way he won [Applause] [Music] uh oh
guys you're doing business
trip tonight
this movie's taught me one thing being good
at racing gets you the girl my parents split
up when I was three me and Mom moved around
a lot it was all because of me kind of made
myself an outsider you know Southern but I
realize now outside our Insider doesn't really
matter all that matters knowing what you really
want yeah might as well go after her get yourself
killed man
oh my God look at them they're all drift compatible
[Music]
[Laughter] today I got my license today I
got my first speeding ticket Born to Race
day after that I won my first race key of
My Three Links I don't know what three lengths
means [Music] what the hell is going on
oh this is getting personal now okay grab
a chair we're about to roast some marshmallows
yo come on man yep should not be hanging out
with the man's girl stay away from her or
the only thing you'll be driving is a wheelchair
find yourself a new driver oh I was picking
on him I'm all right we're gonna just play
with fire he soak the matches in gasoline
Sean you really are a screw-up you know that
man
don't smile at him [Music]
it's over oh this is I am a Gaijin I should
have called this guy change DK
he used to be a good nephew of a gangster
you say I've changed
but we're not so different you and I We're
Not So Different you and I they say your mom
was the best trick in all of Google back in
the day oh that's messed up differences I
know who I am and what up at all
I am the female character of this movie hey
such as soap up with them but I enjoy it I
do I'd be lying if I said I didn't I enjoy
them two together
were you
um
oh I know
a nail and a wood thing foreign
it's still about family
hey brother whoa keep your side deals for
me it's been in the Boy Scouts it's what we
do oh don't don't uh you're just gonna make
it worse what are you doing here
nicely done
oh my God you gotta Drift Away [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter] [Music] [Applause] oh my God drifting
out of necessity
wow that looks really scary to do damn holy
[__] that is scary that is cool wow It's
gotta be a mix of some CGI cars in traffic
right
wow what's up look at that
foreign
drive through the crowd of people they live
their lives in fear [Applause] [Laughter]
foreign [Applause] [Music]
so much drifting
[Applause] oh it's messed up man
that's Jason Statham foreign
[Music]
wow I always thought Furious 7 did a weird
job on justifying how he's still alive and
now I especially think it's weird but screw
it he's back
[Music] I wouldn't do that if I were you
okay I'll go with you
I drift because that would be awesome it's
about family
putting you on a plane tonight I did this
I can't run away remember your advice at the
beginning of this move it pops I'm your father
I'm responsible for your well-being and I'm
responsible for my mess oh my God
I gotta do this can you understand that yes
yes he can the way of the Japanese people
in Tokyo there's a saying about nails and
wood and and don't step on them something
I think Han would have wanted you to have
giselle's body you're gonna need if you're
gonna make it out of Commodus Place alive
you have five hundred dollars in here man
they can't drink and then we're called Gringo
in Japan
here we go it's not just Sean oh my God she
looks so so ugly I've never seen a more horrendous
looking human being
damn you picked you put Japanese well he drifted
into that language I'm here to offer you a
peaceful solution how do you prevent the accomplish
that drift erase yes it's the cops to call
the cause
you could build your own
oh nice symbolic
[Music]
oh [Music] yes [Music] yes it's about family
[Applause] DK picked his role for a reason
he's the only one ever make it to the bottom
not today it's about family or some shoes
now that's sex appeal
look and fly
wow damn they're doing this at night
oh my God the super ugly girls worked [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] oh damn
it's your mountain now Sean
they put those cars close together it is scary
come on dude he is acing this it's going too
well it's going too well
oh man
it's nice to return to a time in this franchise
when there was a comprehension of physics
to a certain degree
just turn the lights off oh my goodness
that was a great shot
[Applause] whoa [Laughter] dude
I mean he must win
yeah
oh [Applause]
you race for me now [Music]
can someone translate for me what he said
foreign
racing [Music] this is like a Fast and Furious
Tokyo Drift song at the theme song
check this out man
God don't like that new look she's so ugly
okay said harm was family
so I heard about that I totally forgot all
it took was that magic word to remind me this
is all I heard about this out he had a cameo
in it there he is
wow he he was younger at one point I didn't
know he was into American Muscle it was when
he was rolling with me you know this ain't
no 10 second race I got nothing but time that's
true he's got like 20 more of these movies
now you ready kid
[Applause] yeah I gotta admit though man Vin
Diesel does have that star Charisma
drift with that car holy crap really they
had to put that out there what was going on
at the time of this movie's release we need
disclaimers like that for all the Fast and
Furious movies now don't be jumping out of
airplanes without parachutes all right well
there's no need for like a big in-depth review
on this you know I think you like the reaction
kind of speaks for itself I had a I had a
lot of fun with that movie that was that was
a lot of fun it's it's interesting coming
from this experience on it because I would
I'd like to be in the position where I was
wise enough to go against the grain and go
and watch this movie in the theaters in 2006
like a good man but instead I listen to naysayers
and I didn't really care for too fast actually
I think I like Too Fast Too Furious I only
saw the one time bottom line I missed out
on it but to go Nine Movies in Miss the what
is essentially in a lot of ways it's it's
more Canon than it's it's actually very much
Canon to The Fast and Furious timeline but
in a lot of ways you know Omni media said
it best because I told him I was going to
be watching this movie and he said it's kind
of the uh Halloween Season of the Witch of
the franchise at the time it came out where
you know if you were like well Vin Diesel
was none and if Paul Walker's on it what's
the point in actually watching it but I see
why people like it I mean it's it's a good
fast I missed kind of these days of Fast and
Furious I think I like it more than 2 Fast
Too Furious even though I don't really remember
it I think I like it more than 2 Fast 2 Furious
and and I I enjoyed it more than even like
F9 uh definitely more than Fast and Furious
did not like that movie that much wasn't until
like Fast Five you know I I if I were to rank
this I'd probably go like Fast Five furious
six fast seven Fast and Furious Tokyo The
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift I'm sort
of winging it I don't really know I've only
seen most of them just one time so I don't
I don't really know if my ranking would be
needless to say I was pleasantly surprised
by this I was worried it was gonna be boring
then again it was Justin Lynn's first film
then he was the main director the Christopher
McCrory if you will of this franchise for
quite some time even supposed to have directed
the last one but then [__] went a little
bit Haywire there and I I see I can get why
at the time it would not be well received
uh you know because especially with what Fast
and Furious is about family certain set of
characters and stuff but I really enjoyed
this one uh I like the Fish Out of Water Element
to it I thought you know going back to the
the time where it was obviously there's gonna
be a lot of CGI in there but not that CGI
Reliant like for the most part it's grounded
in a sense of reality and to get a lot of
the street racing and the drifting like it
was actually really cool and as sappy and
melodramatic as some of these moments can
certainly be where the cheese is really amped
up to a degree where it's you know the movie
itself seems to lack self-awareness in certain
scenes it's not like overly cheesy it's not
overdoing it but it just hits it right enough
to be like this is pretty corny this is pretty
cheesy but because I'm a viewer who is so
well down the pipeline now uh where I'm all
the way into F9 that this to me is is nothing
you know it's nothing like it is so far from
what this franchise becomes that to me I'm
like wow this is like a grounded approach
this is realistic it would be kind of jarring
if the Fast and Furious franchise moved back
to something like this because and it's nice
to be reminded of of a time like that because
I saw the first one uh quite a few times and
then the other ones I've only seen once so
yeah to be seeing to be seeing um to be seeing
this it was it's cool going in the context
of knowing like my real introduction to Han
was Fast Five and Furious 6 and F9 and and
then having the context of Shaw and then you're
like piecing it together like they clearly
did not they clearly like made this [__]
up as they went along like it's not it's not
like some of the best anime you'll watch uh
like I've been reading Attack on Titan manga
and I'm like damn you know uh because the
new Season's coming out for Attack on Titan
I don't know when uh but it's I've been seeing
on Twitter I'm like [__] I gotta like
get a refresher and I thought instead of re-watching
the show read the Manga and then to to go
back to the very beginning it's crazy if you're
uh and like I feel like shows like Naruto
do this like some of the best animes just
do this where you can go so far down the rabbit
hole and it's mapped out better than any Cinematic
Universe you get in America better than MCU
or DC Universe you know any any Cinematic
Universe like anime does that so well and
there are parts of this that remind me of
anime that might sound racist because they're
in Japan but it does there are parts of it
that remind me of an anime uh this is like
the the type of tone the bravado and the height
that just enough heightenedness of it there
there were there were qualities about it like
I wouldn't even call the later ones like an
anime those are something other some other
kind of cartoon uh the this this had that
that nice little punch it was like an american
guy trying to make an anime directed by an
Asian director who I don't know if his Asian
American or actually Asian Asian I don't know
where Justin Lynn is from so my point with
that is when you get to this moment with Han
where he does die uh it's not like the best
anime where you go wow they've been napping
this out since the beginning and we're like
10 seasons into this show but it's so obvious
they really had that mapped out since the
beginning how they get this far it's really
what this did for my experience was go yeah
they were they've definitely been making [__]
up as they went along like let's have Shaw
be the guy who crashed the car in there let's
uh looks like they didn't come up with Shaw
then let's let's let's have him know what
happened I don't remember how he survived
but the explanation was like he just wasn't
in the car and then like he witnessed it happened
he was standing with Kurt Russell or some
[__] right it's I barely remember what
occurred but yeah it's clearly silly but seeing
like the real introduction the way how a lot
of people got to experience Han because I
know this movie definitely got more viewership
than less viewership than Fast Five but the
way a lot of people got to experience on through
this film was cool because it is fun playing
the game of knowing the the Canon they made
up after uh when they did like Fast Five and
furious six but you know it is he is like
a different kind of character here and he
is more of like a gangster and but he's like
the cool gangster the one you feel like you
can still be like vulnerable around and still
be friends with you know he's a really cool
guy and he and to me he was he it wasn't just
because I'm familiar with him I undoubtedly
would walk and I suspect that's probably why
they brought him back and wanted to find a
way to bring him back is because he is the
best character in this film and yeah you know
when I would see like a clip or two from it's
a very different kind of discussion for me
because I've of course been like somewhat
familiar with this movie uh just through via
you know and the rest of the movies and the
franchise and [__] is uh with uh with
Sean i i a big part of it was I just did like
even when I would see him in the other films
it's like ah there's nothing about this is
making me want to go check out Tokyo Drift
especially like when you seem like Furious
7 and [__] like they're kind of fun and
whatever but nothing that was like I wanted
I need to go see that third film they're presented
differently here you know I'm not I'm not
I wouldn't say I'm I'm in love with these
characters but I really enjoyed them I I that
would be it would be it would be a straight
up lie if I said I did not enjoy them I I
did enjoy them uh I enjoyed Sean he was a
character sometimes I'd see a clip or two
and like there's no way I'm gonna like this
[__] but I did they had a very clear character
Arc and they really laid it out for you uh
but I and his he's got a he's real real southern
guy um you hear his parents and you're like
he sounds so much more Southern than his parents
but I I as a character I was I wasn't dear
to him I thought it would be he doesn't like
possess the star power charisma because that
is the thing that happens at the very end
of this film you know when you do see Vin
Diesel and him you're like yeah there's something
about Vin Diesel that is not like the greatest
freaking actor in the world but but he does
he does have whatever they call it to be he's
got he's got that it factor that even if you
really he's not a really great actor but he's
still got something about him that makes him
a leading man and and and uh and you see that
that Charisma there you're like yeah yeah
he doesn't have that kind of power but I was
surprised walking into this to be enjoying
the Ensemble I'd like Takashi I thought he
was a interesting villain who had the complexity
of you know bde energy and uh wanting to you
know be tough and [__] but he's also so
submissive to his uncle there's ah and it
still Falls in tune with the the family joke
about this whole franchise because this is
still dealing with families you know it's
a father and son story and growing up and
there and and then with Takashi his uncle
his is like his father and you know he becomes
so submissive to him and it's about pleasing
him and whereas you got one path of the of
our Caucasian character uh finding his own
way and the other one just trying to be obedient
and a loyal servant to his uncle but that's
also dealing with like Yakuza and different
cultures and stuff or whatever it's just a
lot of fun drama who's the girl let me let
me pull up the imdiba over here it is played
by Natalie Kelly Peruvian and Argentine yeah
yeah they had weird chemistry it was it was
really flat chemistry but it's it had that
it had that weird charm to me though I went
anywhere I'm not I don't feel like they got
some Dynamite chemistry or some [__] and
and the way their scenes played out it was
always the same kind of pitch and the same
kind of note in the same kind of flirtatious
way of talking to each other and it really
felt like the script forced emotional connection
instead of truly finding it I don't care like
that's one of the things with this you're
like yeah this is passable enough for me to
like yeah let's move it along find it interesting
and they had other character moments that
I thought were they would at least make the
attempt to elevate it like with Takashi and
her having that Showdown was right up in her
face there's a lot of right up in your face
action scenes uh dialogue scenes here a lot
of intimidation really close to each other
but you know get into it and and bow wow I
thought was entertaining man is Twinkie I
thought he was really entertaining and then
being familiar with Leonardo Nam and like
other works he's done and then to see him
here if I did not know his other works I would
believe this is the kind of guy Leonardo Nam
always plays do you guys know who Leonardo
Nam is if you don't that speaks volumes for
his portrayal here as character whose name
I don't remember he was number two to uh Takashi
in this film and you know getting like the
the Japanese culture and really letting it
like the the it was like in in the in a franchise
that has evolved into a globe trotting Adventure
it was cool to get an installment that just
focused on one part of culture like there
are some moments that yeah they read a tad
sappy like when they're all drifting together
up the mountain at night and it's kind of
supposed to be romantic but they're talking
about watching them drift and there's there's
a but there's like this weird Community Vibe
about it but then you get like the cool different
angles of it of of an American dude getting
to experience how laws in the underground
World works over here and the Aesthetics to
it it was nice to just have it zero in on
Tokyo and really get to experience that really
get to feel that it a part of me made me go
I wish there was a an ALT Universe where we
got to really find a way to make this work
for the for the for the Ensemble here or the
characters here and and and let their stories
actually continue instead of just being funny
cameos that now appear it would have been
neat because there was something here there
is something pretty special and
and I gotta say like the the funny part about
it is the The Fast and Furious franchise from
after Fast Five were really embraced a new
type of a new type of extremity and it's just
about constantly upping that angle and then
leaning into some of its very overtly cheesy
qualities you know like the family angle and
then you get some new big bad guy in there
who also is what I love about the bad guys
and the new ones is how they they'll they're
they're also obsessed with cars I was watching
the the last Fast and Furious trailer and
Jason Momoa was racing him and I'm like why
are these bad guys they're all the bad guys
are in the cars too it's just it's always
been some Family Feud and they're also into
cars it's good it's good it works it always
works out that way the cards are always there
so yeah it's it is just pure silliness and
I thought there were actually some scenes
here where the drama was hitting just enough
like I was never really strongly moved emotionally
but it was enough to keep me engaged and there
was this sense of groundedness with the racing
and the action where I would you know like
Fast and Furious now it's more like whoa cool
that's crazy and then here it's a different
kind of crazy for example I remember watching
the the trailer for the last one there's this
one little bike stunt for this I think it's
like a female bike rider she like goes over
like this little curb or wall I don't know
what it was but she went over it's really
brief moment in the trailer and it's not this
crazy explosive stunt but it it looks so real
and it felt so tangible and this provided
so much of that for me despite the few not
the few but you know they would have to blend
certain moments with CGI there was a lot of
this where you could it was tangible it you
could feel the stunt drivers behind it and
I know that the later movies blend at but
that's the thing is it's so it's so Blended
in that you don't even really get to appreciate
it because there's so much other crazies going
on that it doesn't even really register a
lot of the time that man look at those stunt
performers and and I like seeing the magic
of that in this film where I am very much
aware that yeah these are real like they have
to do a [__] disclaimer at the end of
this movie of like don't do this [__]
because they had real people doing it and
that to me was one of the most invigorating
parts of it was getting back to that grounded
sense and it's something that I don't know
if the franchise could ever go back there
so it was weird to go to a film to the third
installment in this franchise like let me
do some quick math here minus 13 for 17 years
ago to go 17 years ago and see this where
if it had come out today I'd be like wow this
is the this is a neat direction for the franchise
to go down well look actually it's super old
and and uh it and it doesn't feel it didn't
feel repetitive so as much as I don't have
like an Nostalgia for Tokyo drugs this is
the first time I'm watching it I did find
myself going oh it's a bummer that the franchise
seemed to lose sight of this kind of quality
and it's sad to me that the love for this
film came around later instead of when it
first did come out I mean don't get me wrong
I really do enjoy the other films like they're
they're a blast not a big fan of F9 but the
other films I I really do enjoy so except
for the fourth okay the fourth one I don't
like but five six seven and then pretty much
most debate I really enjoy F9 was a little
bit of a it was a pretty hard experience for
me that was really up and down but I'm looking
forward to fast sex uh yeah now this was I
I don't know just kind of it's like a what
is the phrase I'm looking for um a bottle
what is that [__] phrase excuse me guys
bottle in time a capsule in time a capsule
of a certain time you know it's like when
they talk about movies that were Song of the
South the the phrase will come to me when
the camera's not rolling when they talk about
like movies that were like yeah but he captured
a moment in time of American History Cinema
and stuff when they're when they defend by
a racist villain should exists or something
and that's what this cap it's like a time
capsule of what this franchise once was but
I thought I think when you go back to him
like actually this worked this worked I thought
it was good I I thought it was good and um
I was surprised by how much I enjoyed it I
thought I would be bored I was nervous I put
this off for a while but I wasn't bored I
really enjoyed it and I'm glad I got to experience
it with you all so anyway my conversation
is is just off the rails it's just it's just
off off-roading drifting in all kinds of directions
like how this franchise has become but hey
I had fun I hope you guys did too thank you
so much for being here sure support leave
a like subscribe and I will talk with you
all soon [Music]